j'accueille muriel robin
bonsoir montréal s'en tire et ça va
est-ce que tu vas chez les trucs ce
bracelet c'est samuel benchetrit qui me
l'a offert pourquoi ça veut dire quoi
t'avais qu'à être là j'ai vu un peu en
jambes a bien non qu'est ce qu'en
pensent leurs gammes c'est bien mais
bien ça casse un peu le look qui coupe
les cheveux avoir pendant la grossesse
ouais ça même mais contre sa ferme belle
bonsoir et bk alors s'il est ton
actualité et rebecca ces familles trop
non cette option de famille alors muriel
robin vous avez déclaré au quotidien
belge la dernière heure le 7 décembre
2005 la télévision je déteste la preuve
j'en ai même pas chez moi
les plateaux gémir ans uniquement parce
qu'il le faut pour la promotion à la
télé il faut faire rire immédiatement en
se mettant au service de l'animateur
nécessairement drôles ou talentueux
conclusion je n'aime pas ce que du
touriste vous qu'est ce que c'est mal
tourné parce que c'est beaucoup c'est
bon c'est plus doux que ça si vous aviez
été plus doux que ça je sais pas faux
vous avez raison si sûr non je n'aime
pas la télé je crois que parce que j'ai
pas parce qu'on peut pas avoir du talent
partout et qu'il faut la voir là aussi
que le texte n'est pas préparé et que
voilà il faudra du talent aussi parce
que quand vous passez beaucoup de gens
que vous regarde et que voilà et qu'à la
sortie on peut vous dire que je trouvais
bien ou pas bien tu as dit sa patte donc
on est encore au front et c'est moins
facile si je vous dis à mériel
en données saisies car elle en avoir
fini avec le one woman show avec les
sketches pour vous consacrer au théâtre
et au cinéma
vous avez changé d'avis vous êtes revenu
avec un spectacle sans sketch c'est
peut-être le cinéma qui a changé d'avis
un spectacle son sketch ans est passé de
10 avec les sketches et j'ai hâte et les
sketchs jeudi je fais jeu mais j'ai pas
lu j'avais peur si j'arrêtais les
sketchs voilà que ce sens cette fois
votre spectacle au secours coécrit avec
pierre palmade
c'est pas une succession de sketches ces
deux heures dans la vie d'une femme qui
a eu l'idée de monter blanche neige et
les sept nains en comédie musicale
on est à 15 jours de la première autour
d'elle tout s'agite et on suit ce
personnage comme ça lisa qui parle à 19
personnes qui sont pas là c'est assez
pratique parce que vous avez une chance
de vite je me cogne pas une comédienne
qui jouerait estelle et qui mettrait six
secondes à sortir après que c'est
formidable ça a très vite très vite la
personne est là et en seconde elle est
sortie pour le rythme parce que c'est
très important ça compte beaucoup pour
moi c'est un rythme
voilà il ya du bon dans le fait d'être
seul personnage et tu attendais les
répliques avec guy bedos j'attendais
attendait comme ils étaient tous là on
sent les adresses en ce qui la concerne
à peine seconde alors vous jouez vous
chantez vous dansez vous avez siebel
autour de vous et c'est trés procédure
faire ce que vous faites là
ce qui est dur c'est de rester 1h50 avec
que des mots avec 4000 personnes faire
que le temps s'arrête
être drôle avec des choses qui ne le
sont pas et être son propre héros aixois
entendant une barre à chaque force 10
ans et que ça a l'air d'être facile
c'est cette difficulté qui ne voit qu on
ne voit pas qui rend c'est de ce métier
beau mais qui fait que c'est que ça
reste à faire tous les soirs et c'est
aussi difficile tous les soirs c'est
difficile à chaque fois oui de ferrer
partout tout le temps là on a voulu de
de les tenir de ne pas les perdre d'être
voilà au millimètre said if i swim
aurillac c'est difficile mais parce que
j'ai choisi que ce soit difficile parce
que sinon je m'ennuierais vous avez
quatre cinq mille personnes tous les
soirs au total 300 mille spectateurs et
c'est énorme et c'est à dire 317 f1
genre net à 420 kg formé
mais km 400 même pour tous combien de
passes 5 par kilomètre et alors le dvd
lui il est pré vendu à 300 mille
exemplaires ce qu'ils sont ce les
fermions de 1 million de dvd quoi on
sait pas si ça existe ça rase igad et
jamel il faut un million et demi en dvd
à 20 euros le dvd et muriel château
compte redonner à l'afrique aussi aux
balles normales ou à l'asie où elle
aussi
c'est énorme alors on va regarder à quoi
ça ressemble regardez votre caméra
muriel celcal rouge
oui et vous allez dire magnéto serge
magnéto serge bien